so how was your night
interesting it's always you know it's a
lot of energy being around all of y'all
okay but it was fun did you have fun I
had a good time you know it was a New
Journey for me because I'm introverted
you know amazing I don't think you're
introverted you don't think so you don't
get that off at all
probably went comfortable with somebody
yeah I guess I taught I don't know maybe
I'm introverted too you think so I don't
think so you don't that's what I like
about you because we're opposites so do
you have any burning itching questions
you want to ask me
um or no
no I don't know you
easy to talk to
um so that's nice that's good you're not
socially awkward no yeah try not to be a
leader
I appreciate that
I thought maybe be good if we meditated
okay together right now yeah okay let's
relax first you can trust me
we're listening through our heart and
just allowing things to come and go and
then my voice is just going to be
guiding you to a place that you need to
be and I want you to just kind of sink
into your piece
forget about what's happening around you
just be in this moment that you need
that you want
good just a few more seconds just go
deeper into that I am a new vision
I'm lighter
I am possible
I am
there's nothing that you need it's all
here
let's just connect to it
and we are finally ready to come back to
me open your eyes
how do you feel
is there anything you like to share is
there anything that you'd like to tell
me I really want you to ask me something
okay what did you just receive from me
I mean you're you're acknowledging the
natural Chemistry Between Us
clearly we're both attracted to each
other but we also know that there's
something under the surface that's right
here on your chest you know just putting
it on you
yeah
it's real
you're a cheater I don't play no more
I won't play
it's just like a stranger walking up to
you and be like oh this is what you need
to do to change you're like we'll know
each other like that I don't give my
emotion away to somebody else for them
to manipulate and control me been there
done that it's especially weird on a
date
well I'm Gonna Get You Out My Face
because you're not gonna meditate the
draws off me and so we're gonna end this
right now okay I got a date with
somebody else say I would like to make
it there you can go to a nice restaurant
you can you know you can go to a movie
you can do these things but to really
penetrate somebody's spirit I speak so I
think it went hella great
it's oh so easy it's not fair it's not
gonna take nothing for this man to get
my vagina it's not fair thank you
I guess okay
how you been I was fine till you came
it's really the little things with me
and he brought me some rubber
I mean some roses I need to control my
urges I'm trying to reel it in child
keep it together
my God
what a man we have fun right oh yeah all
the time
anytime I talk to you or by you I'm
having fun oh here he goes yeah
oh my God
you say all the right things don't you
so from one to ten what do you think we
at
honestly I don't know I go back and
forth like we'll catch ourselves in a
moment yeah and we're talking about you
know the things we're going to do and
how we were brought up and what we value
in life and then it's like oh let me
touch you at the same damn time it's so
annoying
especially when I'm seeing them arms
popping out of that shirt all I can tell
you is try me oh I'm scared see it go in
and out
any Hulu Bopper